the Joe Rogan experience the first fight
you had with Badr holy [ __ ] was that
crowd hot that was a wild crowd and they
even like jumped to the ropes and
everything everything went crazy so well
it ended in a [ __ ] up way yeah you
know Badr said his arm was hurt what was
that did he get an MRI or anything like
that I have no clue nut from the
organization or something so yeah he did
some bandage or something over his arm
in the neck because that's what he
posted on Instagram but I don't know I
don't know for me it was yeah you know
it was like an anti-climax it yes it
wasn't the way I wanted to end that
fight right but I think for the rest for
for him this was the perfect way to end
the fight because this is the way you
could get a rematch because if you would
would have lost no point in doing a
rematch if you would get knocked out no
point in doing a rematch so well - it
was a really close fight and then you
eventually won yeah you know but from
for my feeling yeah but Rico walked into
the japs' the first round and everything
that's true but I was pressuring him I
was pressuring him the whole time and I
was trying to feel like where is my
distance where I can hit and where I can
where I get hit no of course that's
right yeah you get tired yeah you get a
tank sometimes so my nose was already
during training my nose opened up so
when he hit it it opened up again so I
was like yeah it is what it is you know
I'm not really bothered by it so almost
fresh impression and I was like okay now
I got now I got it
so after that first round and yeah then
we jumped into the second round I was
fit I was ready for I was ready for this
fight and that's what I like to do I
would like to drag people into the deep
water well you're very fit for a
heavyweight you have crazy cardio it's
one of the things that I've always
admired about your fighting style so you
put insane pressure on guys for a
heavyweight because heavy weights bigger
guys tend to fight at a slower pace and
less volume but you you
push a pace and when the fight gets the
third fourth and fifth rounds you
[ __ ] pile it on man yeah because I've
been training with light guys for like
my whole career so when I started at the
gym I started it with the super pro
SportsCenter with Dennis Carrillo he had
Albert Kraus
he was the first k1 max champion and he
had Alpher lima like multiple
middleweight champion world champion so
I was working with those guys like every
day and they just kept on pressuring me
and I was getting my ass whooped like
almost every day by like guys every way
like 75 kilos so I was like I can keep
hitting him to keep hitting those guys
hard or just go with less power and
pressure them like they try to pressure
me and of course in the beginning is
like still you get tired but at a
certain moment you get like hey this is
going better and right yeah yeah don't
try to hit them hard but just try to
keep the work right now machine gun is
that something that happens in a fight
as well where you have to balance out
how hard you swing versus like not going
full blast but going technical or
knowing that you can start unloading in
the third fourth and fifth rounds you
start season trade but it's for me it's
like I'm playing a game for me this is
we always say fighting is a thinking
man's game because fighting everybody
can fight when they have to everybody
can fight when doesn't matter what
person when you put them in a corner and
it's life or death
everybody can fight but it's it's so
much more than that it's so much more
than just fighting so and that's trying
how I try to step into the ring with
that mentality like people don't
understand that who've never competed
the managing of the resources yes is a
big factor exert the gas and you see
like guys in MMA see it with the garlic
Nick Diaz like Nick Diaz is famous for
not hitting guys hard he just stays on
you just stays on you a lot of volume
and then
get tired yeah and then then he starts
unloading exactly no with big shots so
and it's that's what I like to do the
biggest compliment I could get from an
opponent and I had it like for my like
my last six opponent I got like three or
four times this is like we go now I
understand why you are the champion
I fought everybody but this I've never
felt before and you're on a different
level and that's the biggest compliment
I could get because I'm in there in the
ring for five rounds with this guy and
they they got every opportunity to do
everything they've trained for with me
for five rounds so I didn't knock them
out we just fought for five rounds but
they just did not know what to do and
that's yeah for me the biggest
compliment I could get yeah to be
technical and to just play your game
exactly yeah I really loved your rematch
with Jamal Ben Sadiq yeah that was one
of my favorite fights or at least that
was great like it that was like the the
full Rocky version of a fight that
people would love to see you get tagged
in the beginning and then you
overwhelmed and then when you put him
away I was like holy [ __ ] what a fight
yeah what a fight that was that guy's a
big [ __ ] - yeah he's a big guy
and like I lost against him like back in
the days and when I was like just a
little little kid and so this fight
brought something with it as well he's
like yeah he's a champion now but I beat
him but it was like six seven years ago
I'm a totally different fighter than I
was back then
let's go I'm ready for you so yeah this
was the the best thing and he spit in my
face during a press conference
so I got some extra motivation for that
fight well you played it out perfectly
to where even when he hit you and hurt
you early in the fight you stayed calm
you didn't get emotional you use good
defense and then once you got him into
the deep water you stopped him in the
fourth and the fifth fifth round yeah
once you got him into deep water then
you piled it on and then put them away
but then again it's the same thing for
me everybody
but how did you do that you got tagged
and I said but then again like I said
it's a thinking man's game where I get
hit from my point of view I made a
mistake
I switched the South Pole but instead of
switching and stepping outside of his
front leg I was right in front of his of
his leg and he was just throwing a left
right and I was walked straight into
that and that's what that's what
happened it's not that from our point of
view that he timed that so it happened
and from that moment I can do two things
I can think okay I can jump into the
fight you're trying to get that point or
whatever in that moment back or just
think in my mind like okay [ __ ] it you
lost this round take it and let's go
fresh into the second that's what I did
so just think about okay I lost this
round but I got four more to go and I
got back into the corner and my choice
hey you back so yep okay he's tired now
yeah when he tried to unload on you he
emptied out a lot of gas tank when you
hurt yeah yeah so that's the game right
trying to figure out when you can finish
when you can check me yeah just stay
focused stay relaxed and of course he
with some some good shots but well he's
a big powerful guy yeah he's always a
dangerous fighter that guy's huge
what is he like six nine six ten
something like that yeah yeah then yeah
it's huge in like 270 pounds I think
yeah that's so yeah now it's 1-1 say
come on man you beat me like six ever
years I beat you once unless yeah it was
he had since then all right he won a
tournament last year right so he set a
few yeah so maybe their fight is gonna
come but like I said now I'm in like
last year the 31st of December my
contract was finished with glory so
we've been in negotiations ever since so
from that moment on I said in my last
contract you guys told me
the fight was gonna happen and you it
didn't happen so that's what I want
first
give me the butter fight and from that
moment on we're gonna discuss